[Music]
there's 104 days of summer vacation
that's strange because here in 2020 it
really feels more like 164 days for some
reason
and also more like prison than vacation
the director said let's have fur
breeding a book with an apple on its
cover so the audience knows he's one of
those literary [ __ ]
come on candace if you didn't want the
mustache why did you sit there like a
piece of art while he painted it on
then it must be the day i realized how
cute you are when you're angry
trying to defuse your partner's anger
with a joke oh i wonder what all the
fuss is about
june 15th it's your wedding anniversary
look if your wife is upset that you
forgot a date it is either a birthday
wedding anniversary or garbage day i'm
pretty sure you don't need help doing
the math to figure out which one once
you know she's upset
especially since it was on a calendar
that was hanging conveniently near
enough for candace to reach for it
anniversaries are very important take
june for example
on the third jeremy spoke to me for the
first time back in the seventh grade
may 6 he brushed up against me in the
hall we can all agree candace is a
budding psycho right i mean i remember
the first time jeremy brushed up against
me in the hall too but you don't hear me
squawking about it do you
asking two boys for romantic advice now
that's just pathetic
that's racist apparently this row is the
rock your face off ro
seriously there are faces in front of
them and faces behind them how did the
animators decide what people got poonam
privileges
also the animators decided to skip the
bodies for these floating ovals that
were likely meant to become heads
also also young mom and dad are standing
quite a bit above everybody else meaning
they are elevated on chairs or something
when you tell your kids someday about
the ancient art of concerts and the
before times please make the chair
standards the villains of your story
well don't just stand there man kiss her
kiss cams also considering you just
admitted you've never even held hands
you might want to explore the idea of
consent before rushing into some chin
wrestling i mean if lawrence had a chin
in the first place
truly that was an evening i will never
ever forget bet you did forget didn't
you
no he forgot the day it happened but not
that it did happen there's a difference
karen i mean
candace that's it i know what we're
gonna do today rediscover proper pant
construction poor ferb
and purple body tube has to be chafing
we've learned some alarming information
that when considering land mass the
commonly used imagery of a world map is
a lie
starting your numbers with a zero
pressures from a dwindling fan base
caused infighting among the band members
music video sense has yet to do a love
handle music from behind episode
love handle's music continues to warm
the hearts of an appreciative public
breathing in toxic vinyl fire fumes
phone books
all of these people claim to be love
handle fans but none of them have the
bobby fabulous trendy hairstyle could
you hand me that staple gun right over
there
thank you once stable to hold the entire
right side of the banner to what appears
to be
stone i believe a platypus can solve
mysteries and save the world from an
evil villain but this single staple
[ __ ] is outrageous
dany is standing way too far away from
that type of microphone for it to be
picking him up that well
and his electrically amplified guitar
doesn't appear to be plugged into any
electricity not to mention this guitar
earlier wasn't even strapped to his body
and he just lets it go during the
performance to grab the mic
starting to think this sudden impromptu
overproduced performance is a lie well i
mean what's with all the colors
i have no idea taking your first trip to
middle earth this journey through the
history of rock and roll is great but
seems like it's missing something
something just doesn't feel quite
appropriate wait did i say that white
love on the run at your service my
friend why the [ __ ] does the delivery
driver for love on the run need
immediate access to a cult gun at his
hip in a holster
also this man is highly suspicious who
totes around their elderly mother
untethered in the back of a van i
haven't seen musicians put themselves in
danger for their art this much since i
was stuck in traffic in la and the truck
in front of me had a full jazz band in
it los angeles man
so here's the awkward part uh
and when i say awkward i mean for you
not so much for me finishing a sentence
you started several minutes ago
this is just bad sign design this hair
salon is a couple of well-aimed rocks
away from becoming boobs hair salon and
honestly i'm kind of mad no kid in town
has made that happen
and if we can't well ferb's got a backup
plan considering he's holding a mason a
net i can only imagine it involves
tricking him into some sort of
historical reenactment
certainly the show wouldn't be
suggesting ferb's going to go medieval
on his hiney this wall appears to be
stone and that pick appears to be
plastic so i'm calling hair and anakin's
on this koif dagger
[Music]
why is this bass players montage a
combination of rap and disco and more
importantly how do all the soccer moms
even know the words
barbara chairs on wheels here rollers
dude we're getting the band back
together
roll commercials yeah can you help us
out we're already on
you know what they say about what
happens when you assume isabella you end
up 65k in debt for staging equipment and
have to use the fireside girls cookie
sales for the next two decades just to
pay down the interest at least i think
that's how the saying goes
i'm having flashbacks to dancer in the
dark and this is a sin for emotional
turmoil that that movie caused me
because they're reforming for one night
only they're reforming usually when a
rocker is performed it means they leave
the lifestyle behind not that they're
going back to it just ask dave mustaine
or alice cooper
that guy that is totally thrilled to be
running sound for that church down the
road
that stamp clearly says overdue and he's
already stamped it on at least 30 books
already just saying if they've got this
much of a problem with overdue books you
might just want to shut the place down
all these sweet old ladies in this
carpet from the 80s well smoker the
librarian
okay it's been long enough take your sin
off for these fun songs and let's move
on
and now he stamps this book twice have
you know mercy book lovers avert your
eyes this amount of book abuse is beyond
anything i can bear
that's some impressive trumpet ferb is
trumpeting because i could swear i hear
a whole brass section
so how you ladies doing in here oh you
know just wishing your store had doors
on the changing room lobby so you'd mind
your own business and such
i'll just point out that there's a
massive stage being built in the
driveway but somehow dad who was on the
other side of the fence
doesn't even notice do people have
cardboard boxes in their garages that at
a moment's notice can convert to sturdy
seating is that a thing
we have trash cans we have no trash cans
i took the liberty of going through your
address book
and inviting all your little friends
parents when we last saw them five
minutes ago this crew was in exactly the
same place except this girl was walking
the other direction and they added some
dudes to lift the lights in fact this
girl is still sawing the same board and
this girl is moving the same speakers
that somehow got moved back the only
badge these fireside girls are earning
is the badge for the lazy reuse of
animation this is not their yard
that is not the stage they were setting
up and now i'm thinking this is just a
cartoon that doesn't care about
important things like spatial continuity
also imagine being stuck here or here or
here
up to half this audience has obstructed
seating and that's just bad crowd
planning
also also fire codes noise ordinances
electricity load permits
look this whole concert is a lawsuit
waiting to happen and for that legal
advice i'm charging since at an hourly
rate
he survives this
lawrence is surprisingly calm
considering linda is driving through
their backyard right now
she's right about here and no one
explains why
[Music]
allowing children to rappel over a rock
stage show completely waste owen wilson
in a split-second cameo
shooting off fireworks whenever you
damned well please
come out onto the ledge or i'll jump
right now did you know the cinemas in
writers have podcasts
check out syncast and behind the sins by
searching for cinemasins wherever you
listen to podcasts
come on candace for true love true love
is the greatest thing
in the world except for a nice mlt a
mutton lettuce and tomato sandwich
these guys are 11. hello my baby hello
my honey
hello now you listen here
it is
nobody ever lets me finish my number if
i
this is where i tell you to suck it